springing up at 40 from Yahoo Sports
national college columnist he was there
for that Purdue Tennessee finished what
did you make of that call last night Pat
you know I thought that there was
contact lower body contact
did it affect the shot no but the rule
is that the guy shooter is a shooter
until they're back on the floor so I
mean I think you can call it a you know
you kind of hate to see a game that good
come down to a if he call but I can't
say it was a terrible call Rick Barnes
afterwards said it was a foul so I'm
gonna say it was a foul would you have
called it yeah I think I probably would
you know but I'm a killjoy anyway
Thanks naturally you labeled Oregon
Virginia Virginia's win ugly why yes I
did oh I mean the stretch of like eight
straight possessions where not only but
nobody score nobody came close to
scoring it was just like complete
futility and I mean Oregon's just was
settling for these give up
three-pointers
they were gassed Virginia was flailing
around looking like you know the weight
of the world is on them and to watch the
first game and go 80 to 82 in regulation
in this game nearly one team gets to 50
I was a pretty stark contrast I quoted
you from your column yesterday where you
know it feels like there's more of an
outcry you got to pay these athletes I
wonder where that outcry will be in a
couple years when we are through with
the one-and-done where the marquee
players will go into the NBA and we'll
have these players that might need to
spend two years or three years in
college yeah I think that would be a
great antidote really for this situation
they don't make guys go but don't want
to go don't you know it send the economy
underground and have everybody you know
lying in denying what's going on let
them go pro if they want to go they
don't have to pretend to be students
they don't have to pretend they're not
being paid and you know that I just
think it would work a whole lot better
and
charade I still think college basketball
would be an interesting product
commander there's no denying that it was
great for college basketball to have
design Williamson this year but if he
doesn't want to be in college and he
doesn't need to be in college why should
he have to go to college but if I said
to you come up with a pay scale could
you come up with something that we could
somehow pay these athletes you know
that's a really good question that's
where I think a like a named image and
likeness thing would maybe make it a
little bit easier because then there
would be a market value like you know a
sign Williamson would have a one market
value and Alex O'Connell off the bench
for Duke would have a different one and
otherwise if you're if you're just
handing out cookie cutter payments of
ten thousand dollars to each guy I'm not
sure that would work as well so I would
like to see something tied to name image
likeness where you can sell jerseys that
say Williamson on the back and
Williamson gets the cut of it you know
you can sell other merchandise like that
I think that might be the best clothes
what do you think Sian Williamson is
worth this season to college basketball
if you were gonna put a number all tens
of millions of dollars I would say I
just think that the ratings have been
humongous when they have played ticket
prices have been huge and that was the
thing that really hit me I talked to a
guy a ticket guy before the tournament
started and we're looking at possibly
having North Carolina Kentucky and
Kansas all in Kansas City and you think
that tickets gonna be crazy you know and
the tickets in BC where Duke was gonna
be were $100 higher than that so I mean
he is the biggest ticket driver I've
ever seen in college basketball you also
brought up that a lot of these teams are
under investigation or the cloud of
suspicion you brought up what happened
at Kansas where an assistant coach is
wiretapped
I guess he's talking to an Adidas rep
who is telling him this is what it's
gonna cost if Kansas wants to get Zion
Williamson into Kansas so are we to
believe them
that only Kansas was the one who was
alerted to this is what it was going to
cost again Zion Williamson that nobody
else had a conversation on that he just
went to do it to get a scholarship it
stands to reason that everybody that was
involved with Iowa knew what the going
rate was going to be so you know that if
you don't think so then I don't know
what to tell you the only thing would
that makes it plausible that perhaps
Duke didn't pay is that he committed
like three months after everybody had to
go scared-straight when when the feds
blew everything up and maybe by then the
market had disappeared and you know you
can't really walk around with your hand
out at that point if before September 26
2017 when the feds went public with this
everybody who was recruiting John
Williamson I would think had to know
what it was going to cost to get silence
and you I'm we're not surprised we've
been around this a long long time that
these kids get paid and you know if I
understand why they have their hand down
I mean I understand it and I would too
if if I was Ione Williamson and I could
better my family better my life still
get you know one year under Coach K and
then go to the NBA I understand it
because these kids this is the only
sport you know side from football but
they're not ready when they're coming
out of high school where we say oh you
got to protect these kids we don't care
about kids in any other sport but
somehow we want to protect our brackets
and you know our March Madness here
which is what it comes down to sure
you're right and and look most of these
kids are smart enough to know they've
been commodified from other ties from
time they're about 15 years old the good
ones the really good ones because you
know AAU teams are battling for them the
sneaker companies are coming and saying
yeah we'll pay you two hundred thousand
dollars to sponsor your team you know
they're being asked to you know live in
one place and play for another team an
AAU team over here they know what's
going on here so yet for them to then to
get to college and expected that say oh
well never mind I'm now a pure amateur
is incredibly naive what schools in the
mode
trouble do you think oh boy I mean I
think LSU from what we know right now
just because I don't think there's any
way to misinterpret what will Wade is
saying on the wiretap and that's gonna
be a tough one to explain and as a
matter of fact he hasn't even bothered
to try to oh I know I know and then he
can't say hey I want to get out of
purgatory I want my job back here and
I'm like no no if you explain explain
what you're talking about with this
great offer that you were giving one of
your recruits I mean come on basically I
want my job back
because I want my job back yeah you know
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna explain
anything I'm not gonna admit anything
but I just want to coach so let me coach
okay sorry well doesn't work that way I
think Robert Kraft might have a better
explanation for what he's guilty of then
we'll wait at LSU
speaking of underground economies yeah
how do you think tonight plays out you
know I really interested in the games in
Kansas City I I think Kentucky without
PJ Washington could be in trouble
against Houston I don't expect him to be
able to play it if he doesn't on the
house activity would be you know I think
North Carolina like beats
Auburn 105 to 90 it's gonna be a really
up and down torrid game should be a lot
of fun and then I expect the Duke and
Michigan State to advance to one heck of
a regional final good to visit with you
is always Pat keep stirring it up all
right thank you
that's Pat 40 Yahoo Sports national
college columnist for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
ass
[Music]